what up guys welcome to Pearl daily
where I give Daily News and cultural
commentary updates on what is in the
news this week so today you know let's
talk about the oppression of women we
are just so oppressed by these men our
lives are so hard recently Jonah Hill's
ex-girlfriend Sarah Brady needed to talk
about her trauma
yes yes
and I'm sure it was something really
serious because if you're gonna publicly
come forward with an accusation against
a man I'm sure it's some very serious
accusations that really led to trauma so
she had um an Instagram story and on
this story she showed these super
abusive emotionally manipulative text
messages she says [__] it because she
just has had all this trauma that she
needs to come out now about which is
ironic because he just had a kid with
another chick kind of ironic timing but
who am I to judge maybe maybe this
trauma and horrible Behavior just needed
to come out all right if you need
surfing with men boundaryless
inappropriate friendships with men to
model to post pictures of yourself in a
bathing suit to post sexual pictures
friendships with women who are in
unstable places and from your wild
recent past
Beyond getting a lunch or a coffee or
something respectful
I am not the right partner for you if
these things bring you to a place of
happiness I support it and there will be
no hard feelings these are my boundaries
or romantic Partnerships my boundaries
with you based on the my boundaries with
you based on the ways these actions have
hurt our trust [__] are always the
ones that misuse the term boundaries it
is always women
oh my gosh this is actually quite
reasonable all right he made her take
this picture down
oh boo hoo I have to take a picture off
of Instagram my life is so hard
holy F he went through her Instagram
with surfing pictures and told her to
remove them because of boundaries
literally says anything with a bathing
suit this is a warning to all girls if
your partner is talking to you like this
make an Exit Plan love y'all call me if
you need an ear wow
this is such a horrible existence like
you guys realize Instagram is the number
one dating app do you know how you sound
when you are dying on the hill of
Instagram you know how crazy you sound
all right three removed
not the video yet it is my best surfing
video would you feel better if the cover
frame was different any more specific
ones that bother you yes one that isn't
of your ass in a thong is that an
unreasonable request
is that an unreasonable request
not she says not a thong but k
wow
she just seems like a pleasant woman to
be around and as far as other pictures
of you in a bathing suit or not
I'm done there's tons but I'm just going
back the past month
ladies it's not crazy that men want you
to act differently in a relationship and
guess what
before they started dating he loved her
surfing picks yeah because you have a
dating app profile you put that [__] up
and when you get into a relationship you
take it down it's really not crazy this
is Cecilia she says I feel so badly
about her trying to appease him in these
messages
women hate us
single women especially single single
older women hate us Jonah you're right
we can't do surf social things or
develop trust until you consider me and
make decisions that give regard to our
relationship I have been vulnerable as
possible and I am telling you that I'm
needing you to step up to the plate
which you can I'm sure of it but if
these losers don't get your time if you
want me straight up it's a consideration
I respect your love of Surfing but I
respect myself as well
and your love of Surfing and being in
those situations and lack of awareness
are not mutually exclusive this isn't me
I have my own this isn't me I have my
own issues that I own and if you want
marriage or a family you can't use the
25 card stop and cut the [__] these
people don't get your time
or your kindness at the sacrifice of
mine
I am just so tired of the wine
like you women will die on the hill of
Instagram who cares
who cares oh my gosh like you could you
could take option A just take down the
picture and not whine not fight about it
or you could do option b and die on the
hill of wearing a bikini on Instagram
and keep the pictures for yourself you
can still have them on your camera roll
you can still keep them on your camera
roll maybe show your close friends and
family your surfing video why does this
have to be public but this shows the
mentality it's the me me mentality I am
more important than the family my career
is more important than the relationship
Mimi me me me me
it might shock you to know that creepy
men have arrived to Cape for a fellow
creep wow that's not all what it's not
remotely surprising he infantilized her
feminists just make up words what does
that mean the way he manipulated her
what it like I am so tired of feminists
just using words they just make up these
words and then use them just to confuse
people so we don't even know what you're
talking about so you can just whine and
wine and wine honest to God the number
of people that think this list is no big
deal is terrifying
terrifying all right now Ryan came in
and said this seems like pretty healthy
boundary setting
you think telling your professional
Surfer girlfriend to not post pictures
of herself in a bathing suit is boundary
setting he says I understand that
specific boundaries aren't what I would
choose but everyone is the right descent
boundaries that they are comfortable in
a relationship he literally sought her
out and loved your pictures before they
were yes
guys guys
why do women think they need to act the
same exact way single is in a
relationship do you guys expect your if
you have a girlfriend you expect her to
exact the same exact way single as she
would married
no no that's so crazy and you know let's
let's even say the men are you going to
act the same exact way single as me men
make compromises for us all the time I
bet you if she said I don't want him
going to the club anymore
I bet you they would say oh you poor
thing how could how could he do that if
he went anyway or whatever but all right
this is Sarah Brady's Instagram now
as you can see it's a lot of bikini
pictures now now that she is single she
is super empowered to post these bikini
pics here she is weaponizing mental
health
I struggle with mental health
but I do not use it to control people
like he did to me it's been a year of
healing and growth with the help of
loved ones and doctors to get back to
living my life without guilt shame and
self-judgment for things as small as
surfing in a swimsuit rather than a more
conservative wetsuit and I'm sure
there's still much more healing healing
from this this abuse of me guys do you
see why I criticize therapy they make us
crazier do you see this she's been
talking to doctors
these doctors are not our friends these
women are not our friends oh it's
unbelievable he would send me [__] like
this oh boo hoo my life is so hard
wow
sharing this publicly now because it was
keeping it to myself was causing more
damage to my mental health than sharing
it would ever do can we break that down
it's doing more damage to her mental
health than to shut the [__] up
like how is this more damaging
sorry guys sometimes my manager says I
should swear alas but it's like you
women just bring the [__] out of me like
oh oh I'm so damaged I'm so damaged
because he told me to take off my bikini
wow can you imagine if your sister had
to go through that trauma can you
imagine your daughter wife mother the
horrible trauma Teen Vogue did for me
what couples therapy didn't
my boyfriend says the way I dress at the
beach is too revealing he says I
shouldn't wear bikinis or short shorts I
don't want to make him feel bad but I
like my style what should I do
ditch the boyfriend and keep the bikini
these women are not our friends this is
why I keep trying to show you guys these
women will lead us down a rabbit hole of
self-destruction
oh he says put on some clothes wow I
need to break up with him
horrible life
you know thank you Sarah for giving me
this content I needed something to talk
about today even the person I loved
shared a bed with uses me and can't just
be like yeah you were super nice it
hurts me but I'm done apologizing I was
so lovely to you
this [__] calls this gaslighting
Gaslight much
this is what I mean we just make up
words that mean nothing the right
boundaries in the right place don't
limit their liberate
foreign
[Music]
of hearing about women's healing
what is healing oh I'm gonna go take a
trip to California and meet a surfer guy
and oh this is my healing I'm gonna go
get some mimosas with my feminist
friends well they just tell me I did
nothing wrong and in my relationship and
heal I invite me to one of these lunches
I want to be invited to one of these
lunches she's being our couple therapist
at the same time wow so that
ah the couple's therapist took his side
that's why this [__] is so pissed she
had me agree to paddle away from any man
that approached me in the water no
matter his age I was instructed to say
I'm going to talk to my boyfriend and
then paddle away
yeah the therapist was like you're a
[__]
the therapist was like stop being a
this must have made you feel crazy
do I gotta say it should I say it do I
need to do I need to say it
but you are crazy this is what this
feminist propaganda does to us we are
just convinced we are a victim they'll
just convince us and say oh you're a
victim your life is so hard it's so hard
oh boohoo Fiona I literally just said
hello and leave the convo
I love how your therapist thinks I suck
I literally am the best boyfriend on
Earth
yep the therapists
are not our friends how convenient is
this all isn't it convenient he just had
a kid this all comes out is that
convenient to you guys right it's a bit
weird weird timing it's so icky to see
how I took the blame for him I'm sorry I
said that I had a I had a couple beers
and I'm just upset feeling and we can't
do surf social things without an
uncomfortable situation that usually
feels like my fault somehow I feel you
pull away and then the feeling of being
defective Creeps in I'm not being
socially intelligent enough to meet your
needs as a partner and then I get
frustrated okay she's just she's just
being let's just call it what it is
in the moments collect my brain thinks
of you to dump me because I'm not good
enough and you're the goat yeah okay so
now he's saying you're being too much of
a [__] at these social surf events
I don't oh
oh
misogyny I don't care for your misogyny
I'm so tired you know what's offensive
it's offensive to me that she uses the
word massaging as a fellow as a fellow
you know maybe I'm a feminist now I
identify as a feminist and I'm offended
that you use the word misogyny because
your boyfriend told you to stop being a
[__] I'm offended for the real sexism
and misogyny that I experience so much
my life is so hard Okay blah blah blah
she's just whining this makes me feel
like you're telling me to see
um
these words are very small
all right this makes me feel
like you're testing me to see if you
should keep me around or dump me because
that's something there's something wrong
with me I'm a nerdy dorky unaware naive
idiot socially I hear you it's probably
exactly what was happening I'm gonna be
honest
I mean he probably that's what men do
they're testing you to see if your wife
material you clearly didn't pass lady
now oh my God so all these women now are
commenting seeing your story highlights
that they're disgusting controlling men
and I believe you I hope you continue to
heal and now she's saying oh well thank
God now the public is co-signing me
therefore I was abused these women are
not our friends these women are not our
friends these women are not our friends
I hope my ex has a daughter maybe she'll
turn him into a real feminist men if she
says she's a feminist run
run don't walk run because she'll me to
your ass okay
he says
it's just constant
and does it reflect where you're at or
where you want to be I respect your
skill in surfing I respect how you want
to present yourself it's just constant
but I also respect myself and I'm
interested in my own life and what I let
into my heart and inner circle so
celebrate yourself
and your life however you please and
shine bright and I don't want to have to
deal with it basically he's dumping her
ass it's like he's been texting you for
months babe put the bikini pictures away
put the bikini pictures away
and oh everyone's saying this is so
embarrassing he's like babe all right
look I'm gonna dump you if you don't put
put the bikini pictures away does this
not seem like ample warning
does this not seem like ample warning
she doesn't do it she gets dumped
could have been a housewife but like do
you think about this she could have been
a housewife but gave that up
four bikini pictures on Instagram
she could have been a housewife married
with kids
and now she has
feeling fortunate now she has amazing
women that are single and really
secretly hater these women hate us oh my
God she goes to law school
oh and she put Taylor Swift on there
ladies ladies this is what happens when
we take advice from feminist older
single women and this is really I want
to talk I want to talk to the women
right now these women are not our
friends they will call everything
abusive everything controlling
everything manipulative even when it's
reasonable healthy boundaries and they
don't tell us the truth
and they are more evil because they lie
to us they are big Liars
this is this is your sign talk to your
brothers talk to your dad but maybe
maybe your mom it's like 50 50 you know
what I mean but these feminist older
women are not your friends they're not
your friends they're competing with you
and what they'll do is have you throw
away a good thing
for bikini pictures on Instagram and
they'll co-sign it you lost your ability
to be a multi-millionaire housewife
a multi-millionaire housewife now
for what for a bikini ass shot
and the crazy thing is you can wear
wetsuits he was saying in the messages
she could wear a wetsuit
is that unreasonable
hey babe you know you're in a
relationship now can we put the bikini
pictures away
I don't think that's unreasonable so to
the men if she says she's a feminist run
don't walk run because she will meet you
your ass also make sure you got ring
cameras or some sort of recording
devices all over your apartment so she
can't come back and say oh the first
time we slept together at the beginning
of our relationship like a year ago he
raped me and he was abusive get get some
cameras everywhere okay and also
um
make sure that you get some of this [__]
in writing in text messages so when you
do dump her and she does go crazy it's
not about if she goes crazy it's more of
just a when like when will it happen
make sure you get [__] in writing so if
she ever goes the police the cops
anything like that or social media you
can say this [__] is crazy here's my
proof so next on the agenda Kiki Palmer
now guys I swear I think was Kiki Palmer
in girls trip I don't know anything
about this chick but but what I do know
is she needs a lesson in how not to
embarrass your man in public so last
week we talked about how Kiki wore a
thong to a concert as a mother maybe not
a wife but a long-term girlfriend which
damn near his wife nowadays
um
and got serenaded by Usher in public and
basically embarrassed her man Kiki
Palmer's boyfriend who she has a child
with has scrubbed all traces of Keke
Palmer from his Instagram the pair no
longer follow each other
so Kiki decided this is going to be the
hill I die on I Kiki deserve to wear a
thong to a concert
and I Kiki deserve
to get serenaded by Usher not only did
Kiki
die on this hill now her and her man
broke up for what for what what did they
break up for the father let me okay
let me as a wife and mother put my child
at every statistical disadvantage he's
more likely to go to prison he's more
likely to go to a mental institution
he's more likely to drop out of school
every statistical disadvantage you could
put your child at
you do when
when you take the father out of the home
when it's a single parent household so
she thought well
let me just ruin my whole relationship
put my kid in every statistical
disadvantage
just so
I can wear a thong to an usher concert
again this is the quality of the wives
and mothers on the market and this isn't
a dumb woman like she's successful she's
smart she's beautiful
and this is how she acts so on top of
that Kiki Palmer adds I'm a mother
and I'm Stevie to the [__] shirts on
her official website so she wants them
to know
she's a mother
so not only
not only did she ruin her relationship
she's like you know I want to profit off
of this and then on top of that post
more pictures to her Instagram
this is the me me me my feelings are the
most important
I like this is the level of narcissism
we have in this society and look it she
might be a perfectly nice person outside
of the outside of the relationship but
the point is modern women being selfish
ruins Society because now her child is
going to have to grow up in a single
parent household because she felt like
her feelings were more important than
the family this is the problem when we
don't have women that were raised to be
wives we have a bunch of women
that were raised to twerk at Usher
concerts with a child
with the child so now what do her her
other people in the industry think about
this stuff so at the next concert
um Usher
so I actually I literally don't know who
Winnie Harlow is but what I thought was
great was Usher tried to pull her on
stage so Usher is serenading some chicks
he's like oh I pick you I pick you she
sits on her boyfriend's lap and says no
no I will not be doing that
no no no no no no no
and he goes away
I'm sure you're a bit of a Madness you
were about to take this man's chick in
front of him
it's a bit of a Madness you know what I
mean I don't know maybe he wants to be
in the news but look at other women are
not co-signing this you might not say it
but she knows that [__] was messed up
and this is the thing a lot of us women
will not be honest to other women and
say you know what that was messed up you
should probably apologize
instead they'll say oh this is
coercively controlling oh this is
abusive oh this is
when really usually guys nowadays guys
guys really have pretty reasonable
requests nowadays
you know a hundred years ago they were
like don't don't show your ankles you
got to be a virgin on your wedding night
all this stuff now the guys are just
like please
please don't twerk on stage in a thawing
at an usher concert and the women are
like that is too much that's too much
for me
imagine can you imagine the wives of a
hundred years ago
can you imagine them like like talking
to us
and
asking us
how
okay I'm just thinking imagine having a
conversation with the wives of a hundred
years ago and say yes this is my
relationship problem I went to this
Usher concert and my controlling man
just asked me to not wear a thong and
um he asked me to not go on stage and
get grind and grind on another man
they would be like what the [__] my
husband's at War
my husband was deployed
they'd be like we're in World War One
World War II and now you can't even not
go to an usher concert all right guys
this is to the men okay I say send your
chick see what she says
babe do you want to go to an usher
concert see if she goes see see why not
see what she does
because a girl that respects you is not
gonna put you in a situation that is
going to make you look bad
a girl that actually wants to be with
you is not going to do that
and I hate to say it but Kiki Palmer was
dating a personal trainer I looked him
up and maybe please he's currently a
fitness instructor and this is the
problem when women date men that make
less money than them
we cannot respect them or we choose not
to respect them
even though it's funny a lot of times
like we're just monetizing Beauty yet we
think we're better than them it's kind
of a kind of a double-edged sword but
this is what happens a lot of times when
women date down in terms of income they
refuse to respect the man they're with
but this is the quality of the wives and
mothers on the market and they think we
just cherry pick hand pick the women yet
I've had hundreds of women on my show
say they would not delete Instagram for
a man that's common right King
that's so common
so this guy was playing video games
and spend his parents life savings
on a video game all right
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh 45
000 wow can you imagine
as a parent working your whole life to
have a kid spend 45 000 on a video game
my question too how did he get access to
their bank accounts
have you ever had access to your parents
bank accounts credit cards you probably
stole your card or something oh yeah wow
I have to say look at a lot of people
were hating on the parents for beating
the kid but it was kind of deserved all
right like honestly I think my parents
would beat my ass too if I did that but
it's like a whole generation of these
like video game like these kids that
live on a virtual reality instead of the
real world to the point they're spending
their parents life savings on this [__]
what would you do if your son did that
well getting in the ring
I know
and you I do I do wish them well I just
I felt so bad for the parents too
because now they're on the internet so
they're already pissed that the money's
gone and now they're on the internet
because they're filming it sorry I'm
still gonna cover it guys sorry about
that but
you know I'm on the parents side I I
would beat my kid too if they did that I
saw this clip on Twitter and what it
reminded me of was that how big of a
problem false paternity tests are so one
out of three paternity tests that is
taken comes back negative
guys that means out of every guy that is
suspicious the kid is not his one out of
three comes back negative this does not
include men that have no idea that have
no suspicion so this is a guy in
paternity court he spent five years in
prison for not paying child support
a child support for the defendant Miss
Sears son Dylan that's right Mr Manser
you are not oh God his father I'm here
in prison
you know who his father is yes I talked
to him still she should be convicted of
some crime I should not I did
[Music]
so this guy wastes
waste years of his life in jail
prison
for not paying child support just to
find out the kid is not his
guys this happens every day there are
laws in certain states that will still
require the man to legally pay child
support even if the DNA test comes back
negative
even if the DNA test comes back negative
they are still required in a lot of
states to pay child support if his name
is on the birth certificate and this is
why what my critics and detractors they
don't understand is that this is so
common it is so common
and the crazy thing is we live in a
society where the woman can still say
that she did nothing wrong did you hear
her
I how did you do nothing wrong [__]
you lied to a guy
she says I did nothing wrong
I did nothing wrong
by lying to a guy and saying that a kid
was his that wasn't and this isn't a
crime we live in a society that this
there is no legal consequence for women
that lie about this and if you ask
people I've asked so many people women
should face jail time for this stuff and
most of them say no how is this not
fraud
it's like if I steal twenty thousand
dollars from you
I I can go to jail
but if I she steals five years from him
there's no consequence what would you
rather have 20K or five years yeah five
years since wait the the time is way
more valuable and you can't get it back
you can't get he can't get his youth
back and the whole time he knew this kid
wasn't his
yet
there is no legal consequence and I
don't even know if there was more time
before that if you know how long did he
raise the kid before he realized it
wasn't his
this is why there should be mandatory
DNA testing at Birth
but feminists don't want equality they
don't care about men's issues they just
want power and privilege when it
benefits them
and men like this suffer the
consequences every single day
you know what else they don't isn't a
crime lying to a man about being on
birth control
that's not a crime yet if a guy takes
off a condom during sex and doesn't tell
you that's a crime
it's the double standards that I cannot
get behind why isn't this woman
demonized why isn't her face everywhere
yet
I don't really I've never seen her
before this little clip on YouTube
and yet she lives in the delusion where
she is told and I bet you feminists will
still tell her she did nothing wrong
if there's even a question my question
is how do you not know who the dad is
how many dudes are you sleeping with in
one month
you know what I mean it's like how how
many God how close together are you
sleeping with these dudes you know the
men they're accepting okay they're not
virgins anymore but we can't even sleep
with one guy at a time lady oh my God
this is the delusion and the craziness
yet she has done nothing wrong there's
no problem it's like
and the crazy thing is if this happens
here how many men are raising kids that
are not theirs across the country where
and actually in some countries DNA
testing is banned without the mother's
consent
banned
women are so nuts
but yeah I I think that DNA testing
should be required at Birth for this
exact reason I actually think child
support and alimony should be banned to
the women are abusing it too much it's
like okay the idea was nice but now that
the women have shown that they're
abusing the system the last 50 years I
say take it away take it away you guys
had your privilege we were okay to start
but you guys abused it so now we take it
away so this week Adam 22 has been
coping and it has been the status cope I
have ever seen in my life so Adam 22
pimped out his wife you know he had her
do a porn scene with another guy
um and the cope has just been amazing
watching him like rationalize this in
real time because his first gut reaction
was oh I was a little jealous at first I
didn't want to be embarrassed I I I
didn't want people to talk about it and
now he's just you know getting into it I
guess
um let's let's pull the footage of him
inner him and his wife talking about
this porn scene no jumper coolest
podcast in the world and guys never say
that I don't give you what you want
you've all been talking about it you all
want to hear it
I got the one and only line of the plug
my wife
on the podcast to talk about
recent events I'm laughing because I'm
thinking about how like I'd probably
never come on the podcast again but if
another guy somehow I'm allowed to go on
the podcast
you thought you were never gonna come on
the podcast again I mean
you know no one wants to London the plug
interview
okay you did an adult scene with someone
else but it's like it's when I think
about it I'm like okay cool well when
you were in your like Mom Tick Tock era
probably that wasn't going to be the
thing that made me like okay let's let's
get around I had I had you on here what
a year and a half ago with Flaco yeah I
can't remember why we did that just just
give you a little press yeah get some
stuff out there I feel more comfortable
if he was here I feel really like
uncomfortable with the fact that it's
just you and I and we're gonna talk
about this in front of my brother-in-law
Josh he's not paying attention he's not
even in here
oh he left thank God Josh is in here
don't put Josh on Blaster
um no but this might actually be the
first time that you and I have been on
this podcast together just you and I
right uh yeah it is the first time
that's great also we got married we did
get married that didn't constitute me
coming on here but in this event did it
seems like an afterthought after the
last week yeah not like actually but in
terms of content yeah
um yeah I didn't even really talk about
the marriage that much on here because
it just seemed like it was so nice it
was great the honeymoon was great
because everyone's like do you feel
different now I'm like absolutely not
yeah no it's the exact same we made it
official we had a nice party with the
friends and family and everything went
on the honeymoon but it's like it's not
like the rules changed it's not like oh
like we're gonna do things differently
now we already had the house the kid you
know yeah we did most of the serious
stuff in advance no marriage was like
all right I guess we should just do this
too let's let's finish up let's wrap it
up yeah I guess so okay this this is the
first thing that I thought might be
useful for us to lay out is let's lay
out the chronological order of how the
idea of you even working with other
people became a thing because I have a
memory of maybe six months ago where you
said something like do you really think
that we're gonna go our whole lives
without ever sleeping with other people
and in the context of like I think we're
talking about swinging at first yeah I
mean because people don't really know
this about you and I but you just
mentioned it on the podcast so now I can
talk about it that we had a threesome
early in our relationship with another
guy and that was just like we went out
we partied we had like a really fun hot
sexual experience and we're always kind
of down for like a little bit of creepy
things it was like two or three other
people in the room like we're not there
to see us but they just happened to be
in the room because we're all just
hanging out this is back in the Adam and
Lena party era that didn't really last
that long and at that time to be totally
honest you were pretty much a random
girl to me yeah we didn't have any kind
of like emotional connection oh my God
and
um
I've always been somebody who throughout
my life there's been a bunch of
different times where me and my homie
might a girl together always enjoyed it
I enjoyed it with you that night but
then once we started to actually get
closer and closer to like dating it
became like no we're not talking about
that aim we literally never talked about
it again
we maybe didn't talk about it for like
five six years
do you see I was a natural inclination
is as soon as he has feelings for the
girl he doesn't want to share
it's like he's like going against his
biology like he's like oh we never
talked about it again but you can just
tell naturally he doesn't want to share
this woman yet the modern era is like
trying to program him and take away what
I mean that's honestly part of what
makes the relationship between
that's that's part of what that's part
of what makes the relationship between
men and women beautiful like men should
be protective of the women that they
care about and yet they're trying to
like deprogram that from him they're
trying like the culture is trying to say
that that's controlling that he
shouldn't feel like that and you can
tell naturally he agrees with more
traditional people yet
yeah yeah you see hold pull the footage
back and then all of a sudden also my my
friend went on to to date the guy for a
really long time so that's all probably
also why we didn't talk about it that is
a good point yeah
um but like okay when I think about that
version of us and the version of us that
isn't always going to do who's just very
into sex and likes to try fun and new
experiences I was just like are we
really never gonna have an experience
like that even off camera ever again and
what spread that conversation I think
was the fact that we had had multiple
different couples on plug talk where
either they were into The Swinging thing
or they just did with other people
separately and stuff and slowly it
started to seem like well maybe this
rule is kind of arbitrary well I think
for us it was also seeing those couples
and seeing how turned on they got by
having those sexual experiences with
other people which we had a lot in our
relationship when we would bring girls
in like I would be so much more into you
after and you'd be into me it was like
seeing your partner enjoying someone
else's hot it turns you on so it's like
I feel like that is sort of like worn
off for me because this is the problem
for women women okay because women when
we see the other men select our guy it's
basically it's pre-selection what oh
sorry when when it's this goes back to
this false reality that men and women
are equal because she gets turned on
when other women select her her husband
right
she thinks that men are the same and
they get they get turned on when other
men select their woman but it's not true
it's not the same women um basically
like you know back in the caveman days
or whatever if we saw that a man could
get other women we one knew she selected
him so that means that
that if he could if she selected him
there was a reason that she selected him
and two if he could take care of other
women that means if he could take care
of and protect other women that means
that he could take care of and protect
us too it's called pre-selection but men
and women are not the same and you can
see Adam's natural inclination to stay
away from this sort of stuff yet
they just try to deny reality I'm so
used to it exactly that is the problem
with us yeah like what I feel like
you would think it's hot to watch me
have sex with someone else because we
already know you think it's hot we did
it once
but that was like my dick is in your
mouth and he's your vagina yeah I'm not
saying you DP'd me but like right but
I'm just saying it's not like I was
sitting in the corner because there's a
whole narrative okay I don't think
you're a cook are you gonna go with this
well it does seem kind of stupid
the cuck thing is different because
cucks are supposed to be weak and
humiliated they want to be made to feel
lesser and I don't think that that's you
I think that there's like the more
swinging side of things where it's like
you are turned on by your wife enjoying
someone and then and then she comes back
to you and you guys enjoy your own
personal sexual experiences more with
each other because she did that right
but I mean you have barely even done the
thing that you're kind of inferring
which is like me going and [__]
another girl and just like telling you
about it because the one time I think
there's only one time on plug talk where
you woke up and you were sick as a dog
and so you couldn't come you couldn't
come to set that day but it was a girl
shut up Alvin Jay everybody sign up on
uh onlyplugtalk.com everyone
if you want to see the scene but me and
Alvin Jay we did a scene while you were
at home sick as a dog and uh you didn't
want to see it afterwards you're
actually a little before you left the
house I was in bed I remember I was like
okay go to the scene don't tell me how
it went when you come back and I don't
want to see any clips from it yeah yeah
which is interesting because when you
came back from doing this scene the
other day I wanted to hear about it and
what
I I wanted to know what I was going to
find out I wanted to know like what's
the most extreme thing that happened how
did it play out that's more like me
wanting to like manage whatever the
Fallout might have been more so than
like trying to avoid I don't know like
why did you text Adam after the scene I
don't even tell them the scenes done I'm
just like do you want anything from
Dave's fried chicken I just like act
like it didn't happen
that is true yeah but Okay so we've
we've had I don't know maybe 200
threesomes over the year that was our
rough estimate maybe like almost 100 on
plug Talk Plus a bunch in our private
life plus a bunch for your only fans and
yeah I don't know over time we did just
kind of start to sort of have that
conversation and at first I think we
considered the idea of like swinging on
camera and then that kind of scene
you've always suggested guys I would
never want to [__] yeah that probably is
always unfair trade intentional on my
part yeah probably uh but
he would suggest men that she didn't
it's like it seeps out you know what I
mean like their biology seeps out of
them trying to like erase their biology
and the way he feels about it and like
it's a cope it's so obviously a cope he
said
it was intentional that he picked guys
that she wouldn't want to f
Adam I'm calling me crazy maybe this
wasn't the best idea
I thank you for giving me content to
talk about this week but just you know
we had a nice interview maybe I I don't
know if I would go down this road all
right yeah like it just kind of seemed
like well if you are going to do it for
the first time we should roll it out in
a way that actually
is as exciting as possible yeah I mean I
I
think about like a rollout per se and
then I also like I knew it was going to
you I have a pretty big adult fan
audience and they literally every single
comment on anything I post is like do a
scene with the BBC do a scene with
whatever this person blocked whatever so
I knew that my fans were gonna be
excited but and I knew that the wedding
thing was going to be a factor because
it's like why all of a sudden after you
get married but I didn't think it was
going to be this big but it's weird
because we had been talking about it
before the wedding and sort of like you
know the idea was in the it was in the
air so you know as um the cope continues
they have this adult star that she
screwed
call in call in pull it up pull it up oh
I'm getting a call
okay I'm gonna take this
oh hello Mr Jason love how you doing man
it was good it was good uh we're just
doing a little podcast here and uh
figured that we would uh you know have a
little conversation with you to see
exactly how all this was for you as well
oh my God
cool cool that's why chime didn't catch
y'all see what's up definitely so is
there what's the vibe like between you
guys anything I should know about I
don't think Vibe I think it's like a
business thing but I feel just very
uncomfortable with this right now
I feel a little uncomfortable
can you tell him how nervous I was
well like so nervous oh my gosh I I feel
so wrong right now I feel so wrong right
now like it's just working okay but a
lot of people have like a cheating
fetish like I'm not gonna lie like I
feel like you do yeah cheating I've done
in the past was I'm a little bit turned
on by the fact that I was doing
something underhand or take take myself
out of it but like if you're [__] a
girl and you know she has a boyfriend
she's doing something wrong that is kind
of hot
is it a little bit you see he knows
it's kind of like the adrenaline the
adrenaline like I feel so guilty even if
I was The Other Woman okay so Jason give
me a genuine review
you notice that
they cut something I wonder what they
cut there how was it
you went like a number scale or just
like
numbers sounds like it could be hurtful
but if it's a high number sure like a
four
really nine out of ten who's a 10.
well obviously her oh well it was a nine
out of ten I never I never grasped the
entire tin before it's like you gotta
leave room for something that could
possibly top the next one okay yeah I'll
take a name then that's fair
he said a nine out of ten
wow he's like flirting with her in front
of him he's like oh she was so nervous
but I was like it's ah
oh this is making me crunch
it's just you know as a guy if you allow
that level of disrespect oh
the thing is society has fallen so bad
that people don't even recognize the
signals and the signs of a weak man like
literally if you are in the midst of
other men
in like maybe like a formal set or
anything you're not even allowed to
approach another man's woman without
approaching the man first
but here
I mean we all understand is the porn
industry but the reality is like
this same Adam 22 is not going to be
comfortable sharing his boxers or his
toothbrush with another man but yet he's
very happy to share his woman
um okay yeah so a lot of people want to
know uh I don't know just like if I
should feel diminished as a man as a
result of this like the cuck narrative
is very very yes yes you should Adam
yes quick answer yes yes yes
yes
wrong I just want to get your thoughts
on that and if if how people should
think about that in in the context of me
being you know the the silent third
party and all this
well I don't know like if you look at it
in the business aspect then basically it
was just a job you know
she's high up in her ranks I'm high up
in my rings those two together obviously
would make the move most amounts of
money so it's not so much being a cook
if you're comfortable with it y'all
communicating The Pride obviously she
said y'all did so it's not really a
cooked situation it's more of like two
people coming and making an
understanding yeah you know so if you
cool with it then you know it is what it
is me personally I don't know if I have
enough in me to allow it but everyone's
different everyone have different levels
of
even him he's like you know
I don't have enough in me you could tell
that this what is his name Jason love
thinks this is like
you can tell he's losing respect for
Adam you can you can just tell
because he's saying I don't think I have
enough in me to allow that implying that
somehow Adam is like on a moral High
Ground by allowing him to screw his
woman but he knows what he's doing yeah
he knows this is literally Alpha Beta
like literally go and look at all
throughout history there is no Alpha man
that would ever let his woman sleep with
another guy even for money and it's even
worse when you already have money so if
if Adam was broke I could kind of maybe
understand but he has money so like
there's no excuse them saying well they
want to break record and all that that's
that is total cap I think
um his wife wears the pants in the
relationship and then he was scared that
if he didn't let her do it she was
either gonna do it anyways or she was
going to break up his family or mess up
his money or basically she probably in
fact the way I see it I think she
probably blackmailed him into doing it
because he's let it sleep a couple of
times that she brought up the idea so
well I bet you he wanted to make her
happy and she kept bringing up these
guys
like because I just think he's just kind
of like trying to make her happy you
know like and she you could tell how
much she likes him too but you can just
tell she's like oh I was so nervous
you're not nervous around a guy you
don't like I would say mental majority
well it would be kind of weird for you
to find a dude bigger than you maybe
they could resurrect Andre the Giant or
something maybe you could get Brock
Lesnar to come through and cut it up for
you but I mean you're kind of like with
the biggest dude that I could think of I
don't know it's gonna be tough for you
to find a bigger guy
yeah that's not just the size it's
everything that goes into it that makes
it you know
definitely Lena Lena is just like
shriveling up into a ball right now I
could see how uncomfortable this is
making me very uncomfortable and I'm
glad that he's only you know on zoom and
not here right now do you think that
would be awkward yes also I feel like
I'd feel very a lot of sexual tension
and I felt like we would have to do a
scene oh if you guys were feeling here
see she's out of control now she's on a
tear
I've been known to have that effect I
apologize see all right now I'm gonna
have to really mind you next time you're
going to an adult event that he's gonna
be at right no but I would be turned on
if you were there oh yeah it's like
you're part of it
so you think that if me and you go out
to a party and we see him that there's a
chance that we'd all end up hooking up
after I don't know what
I'm working with you oh wow
I don't care
I get it I get it in regardless damn
that would be yeah I could say that that
would probably kind of make me feel like
I had put a cap on this whole situation
if we all did it together maybe that is
the three-way that we should do because
that would be
pretty viral rather than just some
random guy right
yeah it would be crazy
hmm as long as I'm not sitting in a
chair with my [__] arms tied behind
my back or whatever hold the camera for
one shot all right so now I gotta
rewrite this group
yeah what other what do people need to
know about Jason love since like you're
kind of I almost feel like a large
percentage maybe even the majority of
the photos that you're going to be
taking over the next year or so you're
gonna it's gonna be people saying like
you're the dude who [__] Adam 22's
wife I don't know I mean I know you get
recognized all the time but it's kind of
an interesting scenario that you're in
now right
I got stopped on the street like four or
five times already normally it's just to
talk to me about me but then they're
like oh yo no jumper wife I'm like
okay yeah I guess wow insane
um my wife bro yeah you're gonna get
more of those offers see I've only had a
couple people say that to me I'm sure he
gets that all the time
right so if we do choose to have another
kid how am I gonna know it's mine and
not oh my God I can't no cut what what
why would you even let that be a
possibility oh my and the crazy thing is
he doesn't need money that's the crazy
thing he's just doing this to do it and
the funny thing is it's a me me culture
where you're gonna sacrifice money
you're gonna love to be 80 or 90. your
kids are also gonna live to be 80 or 90.
and now now
your kids have to deal with the
consequences of your decision
and it's so funny because they'll try to
rationalize it and be like Oh my kids
will be fine what if they're not
what if they're not like this is the
crazy thing you crazy parents your kids
grow up one day and they talk and you
can't control what they say forever
so if you permanently damage them from
doing this [__]
I I hope it was worth it to you I really
do
because for what money
money
that he doesn't even need that's the
crazy part
oh God
he's actually a good interviewer too
he's actually a really good interviewer
that's the crazy thing is he didn't have
to do any of this like like I didn't
even know his corn stuff I used to know
his interviews he would do with Like
Rappers and stuff and like they were
really good he did one with Kevin
Samuels it was really good like I'm sure
he wouldn't have as much money but he
still could have been famous and
successful he's a smart business guy yet
he he electively chooses to do this
so he's coping all around all around
Twitter
so Logan Paul tweets engaged to my best
friend how cute is that very cute go
down go down let her sleep with another
dude
then then go to the next one she says he
says
this is the next story I'm going to
cover but Elon Musk tweets at Zuckerberg
calling him a [__] he said Zuck is a
cuck Adam 22 says you say that like it's
a bad thing yes Adam
I understand you know being funny all
that stuff but this is a bad thing
don't release the footage put it away
forever
put it away but this is what we get when
we have modern relationships and women
that run relationships we have open
relationships from guys that are tall
good looking and have money accepting
this debauchery and type of behavior but
let me know what you guys think in the
comments and let me know what stories
you want me to cover tomorrow on Pearl
daily like the video on your way out
guys subscribe to the channel and I'll
talk to you next time